What's going on everybody? I'm here with
my guy IP inspiring philosophy Mike
Jones.
>> Who? Mike Jones.
>> heard of him.
>> Oh man, he he used to be a rapper. Yeah,
he used to be a rapper, man.
>> Pretty lame.
>> Dope career, awesome guy. Now he's doing
apologetics. Isn't that crazy? Weird. Uh
man, we got a fun video for you guys,
man. We're going to be
reacting to this
Muslim
Is he a Muslim? He's a Muslim. He says
he is. Got some questionable motives,
but I mean, we'll take him at his word,
I guess.
>> It is your moral duty as a Muslim to do
this, to be rich.
>> He says that?
>> And to get money.
>> He says that? And so what we're going to
see is we're going to see his view on
how to debunk uh Christianity
in less than a minute or in under a
minute, whatever. Whatever it is.
>> that. It's like 2 minutes.
>> under 2 minutes, whatever. All right, so
let's see, man. Let's see. We're finally
going to get an opportunity to say our
shahada.
>> Alhamdulillah.
Here we go. Let's see. I can prove to
you that Christianity is not real and it
was actually created by Paul and it's
Paulism in less than a minute.
It's not Christianity, it's Paulism.
Pretty clever. He's following the dawah
script.
>> He's following the dawah script, man.
But this going to get you, IP. I'm
telling you, man. This going to get you.
You better hold on to your Bible.
>> Oh man.
>> All right, here we go. Let's see. Of the
27 books in the New Testament, 13 of
these books were written by Paul. Paul
never met Jesus, but he claims to know
everything about him. Oh, so if he never
met Jesus,
>> Mhm. that's a reason to not trust him.
Doesn't that sound familiar? Does that
sound like somebody Somebody we know? If
you had never met Jesus, then that
disqualifies you from being a true
messenger of God. My question would be
to this brother is Did Muhammad ever
meet Jesus? I don't think so.
>> You don't think he he
He didn't He didn't go into the 1st
century and meet Jesus?
>> I don't think he had a time machine, no.
But he's a prophet.
>> Is he though? Uh I guess we're
[clears throat] going to figure that
out. So, if you haven't met Jesus,
therefore you're a false messenger. So,
Muhammad's a false messenger cuz he
never met Jesus.
>> Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah shaitan a
rajim. Let's do it. Paul is the one who
has shifted the entire narrative around
what Jesus' teachings were. All right.
First of all, for you to say that Paul
shifted the narrative of what Jesus'
teachings were, that would mean that you
know what the teachings of Jesus was in
the first place, right? So, what would
he be assuming Like, where would he be
getting this from to be able to compare
Paul's teachings and Jesus' teachings?
From thin air is all as far as we know.
Yeah, all right.
>> It seems like he's just assuming Islam
is true. He reads Paul's epistles and
they don't go in line with what Islam
teaches, therefore he must have shifted
the message. It's circular reasoning.
>> That's tough.
>> But in reality, if someone apparently
shifted the teachings of Jesus, that's a
reason to not trust them.
>> Mhm. Like Muhammad.
>> Like Muhammad. So, if we see Jesus
teaching like, for example, that God is
our heavenly Father, if someone taught
against what Jesus taught, then they're
a false prophet, right?
>> Correct.
>> If someone was went, for example, went
against the teaching of Jesus who says,
"I am the son of God." If someone says,
"No, whoever says that is cursed by
Allah and deluded from the truth," then
that person is a false prophet, right?
>> Correct.
>> So, according to his own standard, if we
look at Jesus' teaching and someone
switch switching up the narrative, that
person's a false prophet. Who falls
under that umbrella that you know of?
That sounds familiar.
>> Muhammad.
>> Muhammad does. Okay, got it. All right.
But see, notice all these attacks
against Paul, he's This sounds exactly
like Momo to me, man.
All right, let's see what else he got.
Instead of Paul focusing on Jesus' life,
he focused on his death and his
resurrection.
>> Is that such a bad thing? Jesus' death
and resurrection is central to the
gospel message, so it's very important,
but he's also incorrect. Scholars like
Richard Bauckham, Michael Patrick
Barber, and Seyoon Kim have argued that
Paul does refer to a lot of the
teachings from Jesus' life. Seyoon Kim
in The Dictionary of Paul and His
Letters notes there's at least 25
allusions or references to teachings of
Jesus throughout Paul's letters. Good
examples like 1 Corinthians 11, where
Paul talks about the night Jesus was
betrayed and he instituted the Lord's
Supper. Romans 14:14 is probably an
allusion to Mark 7:15. And Seyoon Kim
goes through the
uh many other allusions that Paul makes.
So, he's very much aware of what Jesus
taught throughout his life and he keeps
referring back to it.
>> Here's another important thing about
this as well. Jesus, as you said, it's
it's the central message of the gospel.
Jesus said that this was the central
message of the prophets. He says, "I
told you this while I was still with you
that what is written about me in the law
and the Psalms and the prophets must be
fulfilled that the Christ should suffer
and rise from the dead on the third day
and that forgiveness of sin should be
proclaimed in his name to all nations
beginning in Jerusalem." So, Jesus is
saying, "Go out and teach this." So, it
looks like Paul is doing exactly what
Jesus told his apostles to do. Correct.
>> All right, this is nice. All right,
let's keep going, man. I I like Paul.
Sounds like a good guy.
>> Sounds like a good guy. Paul claimed
that his revelations were divine and
that they didn't actually come from him.
>> Did he mean to say Muhammad?
>> I think he meant to say Muhammad. I
I think he meant to say Muhammad. I
mean, cuz look, I I don't know if that's
like a if that's a thing. Muhammad
literally claimed that his revelation
came from some spirit that body slammed
him in the cave. He had a jinn on his
shoulder that used to only give him good
commands, a devil. That used to give him
good commands. And so he's receiving
information from so-called Jabreel, from
Allah, from this jinn that's supposed to
be good, this devil. So, he's claiming
that his revelations aren't his own,
literally. I don't What do we do here?
So, is Muhammad a false prophet because
of that? I don't know, man.
>> The double standards you get from Muslim
apologists is insane. It's a beautiful
argument. So, according to him, if you
claim that your revelations are not
yours, but are from somewhere else, then
you're a false prophet. So, bye-bye
Muhammad. Bye-bye Jesus, because Jesus
says that the words that I speak are not
my own, but the ones of him who sent me.
So, he just condemned Jesus for saying,
"These aren't my words. These come from
These come from my father."
>> Mhm. Bye-bye Jesus. Bye-bye Moses, who
says, "Thus says the Lord. This is what
the Lord says." BYE-BYE ALL BYE-BYE YOUR
ENTIRE RELIGION, MAN. LIKE, this What is
this, bro? Oh, that's That's good.
That's good.
>> Paul also rarely quoted Jesus and he
introduced many key teachings that Jesus
never taught.
>> Paul rarely quoted Jesus and introduced
teachings that Jesus never taught. What
do you think about that? Well, we
already debunked that by quoting
scholars like Seyoon Kim, but how many
times did Muhammad quote Jesus? Um
never. He never quotes Jesus, uh but he
does put words in his mouth.
>> That's true.
>> tell us where we can find Jesus saying
things things. Like, he says Jesus said
that a messenger named Ahmed will come
after me. Have you ever seen Jesus ever
say that? There is no place in any of
the gospels where Jesus says a prophet
is going to come after him named Ahmed.
He only speaks of the coming of the Holy
Spirit in the farewell discourse of
John. That is not Muhammad. It can't be
Muhammad.
>> Not possibly. But he also talks about
how Jesus um said things when he was
like
1 minute old. Like, he was born He was
born and then began to speak from the
cradle. Now, do you ever see Jesus ever
saying this or doing this? Not in the
gospels.
>> Where do you find this?
>> We find this in the Infancy Gospel of
Thomas, a much later forged document
that no historian takes seriously.
>> Oh, no. That's true, but the authors of
the Quran, Muhammad, he seemed to think
it was a real story and he took that as
scholars are pretty unanimous on, took
that and put it in the Quran. That's the
origin of that story.
>> So, you mean to tell me that Muhammad is
the one that's switching the narrative
of Jesus, changing what he did, changing
what he said, pulling from false,
fabricated, Gnostic sources and applying
it to Jesus as if it's real and true?
That is correct.
>> Then he's a false prophet according to
our friend here. Nice. Good job, man. He
I need to give him a chef hat.
>> That's true. He's cooking. Cooking Islam
up. Cooking Islam, man. All right, let's
see what else he got. Keep in mind,
while I'm telling you this, Paul is
acting like a prophet when he was never
a prophet.
He He The words came out of his mouth.
He didn't even think about it. He just
He just said it.
>> Let's go with that. Let's put that in
the video.
He was like, "Yeah, this is good. This
is good right here." Yeah, Paul's
walking around acting like a prophet
when he was never a prophet. Who does
that sound like to you, man? Muhammad.
>> Muhammad. Come on, dude. You got
Muhammad over here walking around like
he's a prophet after being scared out of
his mind when he walked out the cave,
running to his wife Khadijah saying,
"Cover me, cover me," because he's
sweating and and in terror and veins
popping out from his fear. And then he
had to be told that he's a prophet from
someone else. Walked around believing
that he was a prophet and I guess
started acting like a prophet that this
is what Allah says. Like, for example,
there's an There's a time where Muhammad
did not want to tell people that
to to to not come over and stay long
when he's having dinner. When you have
Come over and have some dinner. Go ahead
and eat your food and then leave. Don't
stay for questioning or inquiring. Um
now, don't get it twisted. The prophet
isn't shy to say this. He But Allah said
this. So, Allah's telling you guys this,
by the way, guys. Muhammad's walking
around like he's a prophet.
>> He very convenient revelations just
happened to come up when he wanted them.
When he wanted more wives, even though
the Quran says you can only have four.
Well, a special revelation comes down
where Muhammad
>> He can have How many you ever Oh, man.
Extra wives.
>> Even Aisha in one of the hadiths says,
"Wow, your Lord hastens to fulfill your
desires." Like, she even seemed to
realize what was going on there.
>> Cuz he's walking around acting like he a
prophet, huh? But here's [clears throat]
something interesting though. When it
comes to people who walk around like
they're a prophet, when we look at the
biblical prophets, they didn't have
revelations that were that gave them
special privileges or gave them an up
over the next man. They had to follow
the same laws. They had to follow the
same commands. And if they didn't, they
were reprimanded. Look at David. Look at
a bunch of these people who were
supposed to be who were prophets of God,
anointed by God, and when they went
against God, God dealt with them. Mhm.
So, they were God wasn't just a
mouthpiece, like how Muhammad walked
around like Allah was his mouthpiece to
get whatever he wanted. All right, man.
Man, Chef what's what's his name?
Canyon? Chef Canyon? Oh, yeah.
>> Chef Boyardee, man. Cooking, man.
[laughter]
He over here cooking, bro. All right,
let's see what else he says. Jesus never
came down to spread a new religion of
Christianity. He was spreading the
religion that already existed at the
time, JUDAISM. OH.
SO, THEN WHY AREN'T YOU a Talmudic Jew
if that is true? Yeah, if that's the
case, man, why why ain't you, you know,
over there, you know, being a Jew, man?
And of course it's just complete
completely false. Jesus wasn't spreading
Judaism because he wasn't preaching from
the Talmud. He was preaching devotion to
Yahweh, who is himself.
>> Mhm. He was preaching to people to pray
to him, to follow him, to do the
commandments he is giving. He was not
setting up a new religion, he was
setting up the fulfillment of the law
and the prophets, which is beautiful,
which is Christianity. For for example,
give give me a couple of core tenets of
Christianity that just comes to your
mind. A couple couple of core tenets of
Christianity. Believe in God, believe in
Jesus,
be baptized, partake of the Eucharist or
communion. Core tenets, these are things
Jesus taught.
>> things that Jesus said verbatim. He
taught that to believe in God. He said,
"Believe in God, believe also in me."
Mhm. He says that for for God so loved
the world that he gave his only begotten
son that whoever believes in him should
not perish but have everlasting life.
Whoever does not believe in the name of
the only son of God, they are condemned
already. He says that when when he talks
talking about the Eucharist, he says,
"Take this and do this in remembrance of
me. This is my body which is broken for
you. This is my blood which is poured
out for you for the forgiveness of sins,
the blood of the new covenant." These
are all things Jesus taught, the
fulfillment of the old covenant. Nothing
in that matches with Islam. As a matter
of fact, all of Islam goes against
everything we just said, everything
Jesus just said. Exactly. Yet then Paul
comes around and starts the church and
starts Christianity, which is not
something that Jesus started.
>> Mhm. [clears throat] So, Paul comes
around and starts the church and starts
Christianity, which is something that
Jesus never started. So, did Paul start
the church, man? Uh no. Really? No. Cuz
he said he he said it.
>> Well, then you just you have to actually
read the New Testament. We can go to a
book that Paul didn't write, the book of
Matthew,
>> Mhm. where Jesus says, "Upon this rock I
will build my church."
>> Mhm. Okay? That doesn't come from Paul,
that comes from Jesus in the Gospel of
Matthew. So, who started the church?
Jesus did. Paul was following the
teachings of Jesus and the teachings of
the early church. Okay.
Okay, okay, I got to take a Chef Hat
away from that on that cuz that was that
was kind of bad.
>> bad. If he's talking about what Jesus
started, right?
If you're you're a false messenger, if
you are starting something that Jesus
didn't start. So, like circling the
Kaaba, kissing the black stone,
promoting multiple wives,
>> Mhm. uh promoting beating of wives,
things of this nature, right? Jesus
never started those things.
>> Correct.
>> Jesus never started those practices.
>> Muhammad started all of these things.
Like, well, he didn't start the circling
of the Kaaba, but he integrated this
pagan practice within his religion,
which is something Jesus never did.
>> Correct.
>> So, then Muhammad's a false prophet.
>> false messenger, he's unreliable, he's
untrustworthy. We we shouldn't be WHY
WHY WHY ARE WE treating him like a
prophet when he never was? Right? Right.
Okay. All right. Just making sure we we
keeping the same energy. For me, it
doesn't really make any sense. If we're
supposed to be listening to Jesus if
we're Christians, why are we listening
to Paul? Exactly. If we're supposed to
be listening to Jesus, why are we
listening to Muhammad?
>> Exactly.
>> Why are we following Muhammad? When
Jesus says that the seal of the Father
is placed on him, why are we listening
to Muhammad when he says that he's the
seal of the prophets? If we're if we're
supposed to be following Jesus who says,
"I died for you. I gave my body up. This
is my blood. This is poured out for
you." Why are we following Muhammad that
says it was just made to appear so? I
don't know. It's a good question for
Muslims. That's tough. So, it looks like
you need to stop following Muhammad and
start following Jesus. Once you start
doing that, man, you going to be on the
right track. I promise you, boy.
>> And also, Paul didn't contradict the
teachings of Jesus, okay? He added
commentary. He explained things that
were taught in the early church that
came from Jesus. He didn't outright
contradict him like Muhammad did.
>> Right. And why does Paul have any
authority? And Paul is not a prophet, so
why are we treating him like one? How
can someone who's never met Jesus tell
us the teachings of Jesus that we're
supposed [music] to be following?
>> Exactly.
Well said.
>> Oh my God, that's beautiful. How can
someone who never met Jesus, had no
connection to Jesus, had no connection
to people who knew Jesus, or the people
who knew the people that knew Jesus, how
can they tell us anything about what
Jesus taught and what we ought to
follow? How can someone who came in 600
years la- later, uh hundreds of miles
away from said events, generations away
from said events, tell us about Jesus
and anything that he taught?
>> know. It's a good question for Muslims.
We should ask them that sometime. So,
what who what does the evidence lead to?
Does does the evidence pound up
Muhammad's side, or does it more lean
towards Paul? Cuz it sounds like Paul is
actually in that ballpark, yeah? Seems
like he is, yes. Okay. So, we got Paul.
Did Paul meet Jesus? Not during his
earthly ministry.
>> Not during his earthly ministry, but did
he have an experience with Jesus? Yes,
he said he experienced Jesus on the road
to Damascus, yeah. Okay. So, he
experienced Jesus on the road to
Damascus. Now, is that his own single
testimony, or did other people attest to
that?
>> Other people attested to it. Luke
attested to it in the book of Acts, for
example.
>> Wow. So, Luke attested to it. Didn't
somebody named Ananias also get a
revelation confirming Paul's revelation?
>> In the book of Acts, which Paul did not
write,
>> [clears throat]
>> Luke tells us that this guy also
received word from Jesus that this did
happen. Wow. And then what happened when
Paul went to Peter, James, and John? Did
they say, "Hey, no, you're a heretic.
You were persecuting the church. You're
not with us." or did these people who
were called by Jesus, direct apostles
and disciples of Jesus, what did they
say to Paul when he came and met them?
In the book of Galatians, Paul says they
added nothing to what I was preaching.
So, they were on the same page, and we
have no evidence whatsoever from the
first century that what Paul was
teaching contradicted what the disciples
and James were teaching. That's
beautiful. So, it looks like Paul is
winning in this area of being acquainted
with Jesus, being acquainted with people
who knew Jesus, being acquainted with
the scriptures that Jesus was following
and teaching and and fulfilling. Paul
fits the bill of a true messenger called
by God, while Muhammad is failing every
criteria that our friend here is
bringing out.
>> It's uh it's like he didn't even think
about this before he put the video out.
>> That's tough. And if I'm going to make
an assumption based off not knowing too
much, I would think that Paul was doing
it for personal gain.
>> No, you're making a lot of assumptions,
buddy. I mean, a lot. And it's based on
you not knowing a thing. You don't know
anything, and you're making all of these
assumptions.
>> Mhm. Beautiful run of the Dallas game.
But he just said that he he would say
that Paul was doing this out of personal
gain.
>> Personal gain, huh? Okay, so he was
being persecuted, beaten,
[clears throat]
whipped by the Jews, receiving lashings,
is how he puts it. And what happens? He
gets martyred at the end of his life.
>> Oh, that's He set up churches, moved
from town to town, wasn't taking money
from them, but had to keep writing
letters back to them to correct their
misunderstandings and their mishaps.
This doesn't sound like he was having a
great time or getting a lot of gain.
>> Mhm. What about Muhammad, though? Well,
he was a warlord, he was getting a lot
of plunder from the people that he was
attacking.
He had multiple wives, including a child
bride, who was
getting a lot of crazy stuff. Seems like
he was getting a whole lot from his
supposed revelations he was saying.
>> And just like what Aisha said, what did
you quote her? What did she say?
>> Wow, your Lord hastens to fulfill your
desires.
>> Your Lord hastens to fulfill your
desires. So, who is it we are even from
one of the from the child bride herself,
uh demonstrating that that Muhammad
seems to be getting a lot of personal
gain from his so-called prophethood.
>> Very interesting.
>> Very interesting, indeed.
>> Because he didn't know Jesus, and he's
the one telling us Jesus said that,
Jesus said this. Like Muhammad. Like
Muhammad.
>> Like Muhammad, okay. Where's the proof?
Find me [music] the proof that says that
Paul is an authority and we should
listen to him. That's a good You know, I
like I'm glad he asked that, man. Find
us the proof that that Paul is an
authority and that we should listen to
him. So, this is Acts chapter 13,
>> Mhm. Good job. verse two. And this is
what it says here, guys. It says, "While
they were worshipping the Lord and
fasting, the Holy Spirit said." So,
who's speaking here? The Holy Spirit,
God himself, says, "Set apart for me
Barnabas and Saul for the work at that
which I have called them." So, right
here we see very clearly that Paul has
divine authority to be sent out on the
work that God has called him. Mhm. Proof
enough? That seems like it's good enough
for me. Okay, that's Bible right there.
Is that the truth? That's the truth. Is
that the truth?
>> That's the truth.
>> Then he lied. And this just reminds me
of why I love the religion of Islam.
Because in Islam, there's no confusion
like this. It just makes simple sense.
Worship Allah, and that is it.
>> And there you have it, guys. All you got
to do is worship Allah, and that's it.
>> And pray five times a day facing Mecca.
You have to believe, according to the
Hadith, that Allah has two right hands
and a shin. No confusion. No confusion.
Um you got to believe that his foot is
in hell because Allah promised to to
fill it up, and so he couldn't just snap
his fingers and fill hell, he had to put
his foot down there to fulfill his
promise that hell will be filled, so.
>> Allah descends to answer prayers Mhm. at
at the third of every night
>> Third of every night, yeah. uh asking
who's praying to him.
That Jews and Christians are going to
take the place of Muslims in hellfire,
and Allah's going to say, "That's your
ransom. That's your rescue from the
hellfire."
>> But meanwhile, Sura 5:69 says that Jews
and Christians, as long as we worship
God and do good works, we're okay, good
to go. So, it sounds like we have a
contradiction there.
>> Uh wait, hold on. So, wait, I'm going to
go to hell according to the Hadith for a
Muslim, but according to the Quran, I'm
good to go? Yep.
So, much confusion. See,
>> what you're talking about. The Quran
says it's a perfectly clear book of
everything. That's That's exactly why I
love Christianity, because Christianity
is so simple. Uh all you got to do is
believe in one God who is triune,
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, perfect
unity, inseparable in their fellowship
and communion, and believe in the Son of
God who came to die for our sins, rose
again on the third day, did the work for
us that we could not do, gave his life
for our sins, for our salvation. We
believe in him, and our good works
follow that. And that is the gospel
message of Christ. That's what he
taught. Man, I love Christianity, man.
Sounds good to me.
>> Sound good to me, man.